first we just witnessed more blatant
malicious deception smears lies post
murchman from the mob and the media look
at this article in the New York Times it
is entitled they below bar owner was
skeptical about the virus then took a
cruise Times columnist while this
woman's name is jinnia Belafonte pretty
much all but accused yours truly of
murder the story featured a well liked
New York Bar owners name was Joe Joyce
apparently an avid fan of Fox News first
I want to stop with all my heart I want
to extend my sympathy to mr. Joyce's
friends so well-liked apparently his
family his loved ones and mr. Joyce
apparently was a very special person I'm
sure this is very hard on all of them
and so many other people that are
dealing with what the president rightly
calls an invisible enemy it is an enemy
now The Times claimed that because of
something I said in early March March
9th to be exact
well Joyce decided it would be okay to
take a cruise to Spain now they claim he
ultimately contracted coronavirus didn't
quite tie it to the cruise completely
and sadly he passed away now this is
where the New York Times slander begins
in order to smear yours truly they
literally this woman exploited a man's
tragic death she willingly maliciously
purposefully took something I said
completely out of context and as proven
by all my past statements that the New
York Times was very well aware of and it
gets worse there were marks that she
used yes they were from March the 9th
again taken out of context it was also 8
days after mr. Joyce embarked on his
cruise those are the remarks she
referred to in her slanderous piece that
is slander that is libel and forget
about me in all of this politicizing a
tragedy this New York Times so-called
writer reporter whatever she is has
added to the pain and suffering of a
family that deserves better this was all
done to vilify this program in this
channel and that's not all as a reporter
Joel Pollock of Breitbart calm and then
multiple other
let's to their credit pointed out that
when the New York Times got caught
spreading the line in other words whoops
he already took the cruise yeah we
messed that up what they did is they
didn't make a correction they didn't
highlight a change they just tried to
sneak it in a stealth edit in the
article in other words to include a more
accurate timeline considering they
botched it the first time and by the way
that completely contradicted the entire
thesis of their article a real
journalist a real newspaper would admit
that they were wrong issue an apology
issue a correction in an interesting way
their stealth edit is nothing but an
admission of their guilt and an example
how they tried to cover up their smear
their slander their lies and everything
else
miss Belafonte she's a hack she works
for a disgraceful organization the same
people that lied Russia Russia and peach
and peach Ukraine Ukraine and Kavanagh
Kavanagh same people that protected
Clinton that protected call me the deep
state and that never investigated the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in history because they were too
billing busy spreading conspiracy
theories and more hoaxes and by the way
yet another example of beyond
journalists malfeasance here they're
culpable and quietly editing the content
when they are caught red-handed and by
the way that's not where the story ends
it gets worse for them On February 27
three days before mr. Joyce decided to
go on his cruise the same New York Times
hack that tried to blame me for his
death jinniyah Belafonte she tweeted
this I fundamentally don't understand
the panic incidents of the disease is
declining in China and by the way the
virus is not deadly in vast majority of
cases production and so on will slow
down and we'll obviously rebound okay
that is the type of behavior by the way
same New York Times five or six days
after the president put the travel ban
in effect that would be the same New
York Times that said it who says it's
not safe to travel to China uh-huh
bad advice there too this is the kind of
rampant hypocrisy negligent behavior
that is so widespread the
is the 99% of the mob and the median I
call them a mob for a reason they are
nothing but state-run print state-run TV
they are the allies of all things
radical Democratic socialists and
extremists tonight their pattern of
misconduct can be broken down into three
categories let's look at one the new
york times played down they ignored the
virus number two they politicize the
virus remember they used it to call the
president a racist with the travel ban
and they accused the president Fox News
yours truly this program not taking the
virus seriously enough they were given
all the evidence to the contrary for
more details let's look at our
comprehensive timeline New York Times
January 8 they report a quote there is
no evidence that the new virus is
readily spread by humans okay keep in
mind in January China was involved in a
massive cover-up in the information that
we were getting was full of lies
completely inaccurate January 14th world
health organization remember them
we paid those bills Chinese authorities
have found no clear evidence of
human-to-human transmission January 15th
Kovan 19 well remember it wasn't even on
nancy pelosi's radar top Democrat in the
country was all smiles she's doing the
selfies giving away pens you know
signing off on her big impeachment stunt
with commemorative everything but only a
week later January 21st the first case
January 21st the first case the corona
virus in the US on that very same day
even America's top experts well I'm a
ton of respect for he has spent a life
he has saved lives all throughout his
career he didn't understand it either he
was being lied to to doctor foul she
said this is not a major threat to the
people of the United States January 26
now she reiterated the virus is quote
very very low risk to the United States
I'm not attacking dr. pouchy he was
working with Chinese lies as spread by
the World Health Organization and of
course I had him on my show on January
27 two days later yet people like
BuzzFeed publishing a headline don't
worry about the coronavirus worry about
the flu Oh CNN was saying that on March
the fourth we'll get to that January
31st slocks tweeted
is this going to be a deadly pandemic no
same day Washington Post published a
piece with the headline how our brains
make coronavirus seem scarier than it is
now the president he doesn't seek the
advice thankfully from the Washington
Post the media ma box any of them
because 10 days after the first case
emerged in this country your President
President Donald J Trump made the
boldest decision to ban travel to and
from China he declared a public health
emergency
it is incalculable incalculable
how many untold thousands of Americans
did not contract this disease and untold
American lives were saved by the way he
got nothing but criticism racism
xenophobia fear-mongering hysteria this
decisive action though ten days after
the first case it bought us time it
saved us from an immeasurable amount of
suffering the mob and the media they
were outraged fake News CNN accusing the
president of using the corona virus to
spread fear and racism and xenophobia I
told you they just echoing quid pro quo
Joe well I should impose to early
February their headline was this why we
should be wary of an aggressive
government response to coronavirus
February 4th what was Nancy Pelosi doing
remember she was doing the little pre
tears then she could have her public
well temper tantrum preordained of
course for the president State of the
Union address but the cameras by the way
the president that night was talking
about Kovan 19 she was busy ripping and
get this February 5th your beloved New
York Times the same paper accusing me of
downplaying the virus when just the
opposite is true and I will prove it ran
this headline who says it's not safe to
travel to China New York Times was
advising you to go over to China that
was dumb the coronavirus travel ban is
unjust they said it doesn't work anyway
two separate democratic debates in
February hmm no not one candidate on
stage mentioned the coronavirus not one
meanwhile New York city's health
commissioner was also downplaying the
threat of the virus take a look
at the risk to New Yorkers for
coronavirus is low and that our
preparedness as a city is very high
there is no reason not to take the
subway not to take the bus not to go out
to your favorite restaurant now let's
fast forward to February 24th
now remember Trump put the travel ban in
effect almost a month earlier okay we're
the middle of a public health emergency
there's Nancy Pelosi showing up
publicity stunts crowded streets San
Francisco's Chinatown hugging shaking
hands with her supporters and
encouraging everyone to go and socially
on distance February 26 yep The Times
ran another unhinged op-ed entitled
let's call it Trump virus why does the
New York Times doesn't like me if you're
feeling awful you know who to blame
in March fake news CNN said that calling
the coronavirus wuhan or China
coronavirus was racist
even though fake news acosta himself
used the exact same terminology in
January on March the second there's
mayor of New York Konrad de Blasio
encouraging New Yorkers to go out on the
town and catch a play same day Governor
Cuomo said well excuse our arrogance but
this disease will not be as bad in New
York as other countries it was worse and
on March the fourth fake news CNN
Anderson Cooper is what he had to say
about the virus let's pay attention to
his timeline half the people in America
do not get a flu shot and the flu right
now is far deadlier so if you're freaked
out at all about the corona virus you
should be more concerned about the flu
and you can actually do something about
it and get a flu shot the facts on the
ground are the facts on the ground they
didn't change at different times we have
to concede even with dr. pouchy February
29 was saying the risk is still low
March 9th doctor pouch even said for
healthy people they could still go on a
cruise ship but that statement never
made it into this weekend's New York
Times hip piece against this program
they hate all things Trump all things
conservative and they hate Sean Hannity
likes Donald Trump and says so on radio
and TV
neither did
watch my timeline which by the way I
spent an entire hour going over with one
of their top-notch fake news reporters
and it's been posted on Hannity dot-com
I believe since March the 18th we had
dr. pouchy on this program as early as
January 27th discussing the serious
nature of the virus the next day I
talked to a panel of doctors February
10th I had dr. pouchy back on to talk
about what about these people that are
asymptomatic and the spread of the
disease
it's all there Hannity you can see it
all Hannity calm at Sean Hannity Twitter
we've got it all there in print for all
you liars all of you involved in smear
slander besmirched and all of you
character assassins you can all read you
might actually learn something we
praised the president's bold action to
halt travel from China that was a game
changer this has been the biggest
medical mobilization in the history of
this country
okay everyone that needed a ventilator
got a ventilator not because any state
had any of them hospitals were built in
under a week including the Javits Center
the Navy ships were sent the ventilators
were sent the mast the gowns the gloves
the respirators all sent record time
never seen anything like it lives were
saved none of that made it into the fake
news New York's libel slander Times
article that's because the so-called
journalists who worked there and not
interested in the truth that is a fact
instead they care about bludgeoning
enemies for that meta me number one is
not me that would be President Trump
enemy number two is anybody and
everybody including voters that support
President Trump
New York Times is not alone look at how
fake News CNN and yes conspiracy
television Roswell Rachel Maddow same as
DNC covered this serious virus over the
past few weeks take a look in the middle
of it a national emergency political
the president is sounding very
Baghdad Bob Lake in the way that he's
signing blamed it to everybody but
himself there are tens of thousands of
people who will die in the country or
had some hope of them have already
more are still going to die because of
Donald Trump's incompetence here we have
a president who is exploiting a national
crisis to move forward his own agenda
his own revenge his own profit the
president determined to rewrite the
history of his early and reprehensibly
irresponsible response to this virus but
he's still acting reckless and unmoored
here in the United States we are still
not doing what we need to do to fight
this deadly virus because of a complete
lack of leadership do you think there's
already do you think there is blood on
the president's hands considering the
slow response Wow for the people you
just saw this virus yep unfortunately
they politicized it pretty early on one
more opportunity because they got
everything else wrong about Donald Trump
Russia Ukraine and Pietschmann never
investigated the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in history that we
got right they got wrong